uh i love variations of this joke uh
because everyone hates lawyers
until you need one and then then who are
you gonna call
hmm
[Music]
meme review meme review trademark of
pewdiepie all rights preserved
all right let's just get at it legal
memes 2021 style let's do it
i graduated from law school six years
ago with 250 000
of student loan debt after years of hard
work and tens of thousands of dollars of
payments
i can officially say now that i owe 315
thousand dollars
very very true law school is extremely
expensive uh 250 000
a quarter million dollars for three
years not
unusual if you are making the minimum
payments
uh yeah that amount can actually
increase over time
now lawyers do tend to make more than
the national
uh median salary but that doesn't mean
that the amounts they pay for law school
aren't huge i know a lot of people who
owe more now
than they did when they graduated and of
course a lot of people
rely on loan forgiveness they might work
for a public interest law firm
or they might work for the government in
the hopes that over time they will
have their loans forgiven by the
government which can happen
uh there were talks of scaling that back
but man it's uh it's kind of a crapshoot
you know what if you leave the
government
uh job it uh it can really work out
poorly sometimes so uh
toss a coin to your lawyer
the first thing i learned in law school
is to check how long something is before
i start reading it
this is actually really really good
advice not all cases are created equal
in
law school you get these case books you
are supposed to read these cases
but some cases are 20 30 50 pages long
and other cases
are condensed and they might only be two
pages long and the amount of information
that you're probably going to take from
each one of these cases is about the
same
everyone has a limited amount of time in
law school i have a whole course on how
to do well in law school and time
management is a huge huge portion of
that
knowing that you might have to skim one
case as opposed to reading one case in
depth and
maybe knowing ahead of time which cases
are the important ones and which ones
are filling in some background idea
super super important
this guy gets it for sure
all right keeping with the law school
theme law school has taught me the
valuable skill of discussing the
readings without having read the
readings hashtag lost in problems
yeah the other part of that would be
sometimes you're not able to get to all
of the readings
it takes forever to read these cases and
you might have
literally hundreds of pages to read per
night in law school now there's a whole
cottage industry of
supplements that help you get through
this and synthesize everything into
smaller more manageable pieces
but sometimes there's just way too much
reading and
you have to let things slip of course
you have to worry about the socratic
method so that if you're not prepared in
class the
professor might call on you it might
grill you and you might not have done
the reading
and that doesn't turn out well just you
know see what happens in legally blonde
now i assume all of you have read pages
1 through 48 and are now well versed in
subject matter jurisdiction
which is quasi-realistic i guess
okay uh out of the law school and into
the practice when you check in with the
clerk and try to get priority
with with the sunglass shades so here's
the background here
every courthouse has a court clerk
they're an administrative official but
they can sort of control your destiny
there might be a court clerk for the
whole courthouse
and there might be a court clerk for the
particular judge that you're in front of
and they control the calendars of the
judges so sometimes you
should probably spend some time getting
to know your court clerk at least being
nice there's so many lawyers who are
just
really really mean to these court clerks
thinking that they're
uh you know beneath them to talk to them
but in reality a court clerk is the
grease that makes the wheels of the
courthouse work so you better be nice
and uh you know metaphorically slide
into their their dms i guess
i hate citations why can't you just
trust me
oh my gosh having practiced law for
i don't know 12 or 13 years now
citations are
the lifeblood of any legal brief you
have to cite
any proposition of law that you're
saying to the judge otherwise
court and counsel will look at whatever
you have just said with a great deal of
suspicion no one's going to trust your
citations and the funny thing is when we
do scripts here on legal eagle you don't
usually see it but the scripts
have on average 75 or 100 citations
because
we have to do a lot of research because
we can't get these things wrong whether
we're putting something in front of the
judge or putting something in front of
all the people on youtube
the citations are important and although
you might not see the citations they are
definitely there
unemployment checks murder hornets
quarantine loan debt coronavirus
i'll go to law school that's fine that's
fine
oh my god uh yeah so shed a tear for the
law students who have been going to law
school
in 2020 and 2021 it's completely
different it's all virtual
you are losing out on a whole lot of the
advantages of
law school and it's it's really
unfortunate and not only is it
the whole world is sort of on fire or
whatever
but yeah to add law school on top of
that and you don't even get to interact
with people in person now
maybe that's a good thing because you're
not getting the stress by proxy of all
your fellow law students
man that would be really tough to add on
all of this stuff with law school itself
though on the other hand
you know you're not going to interact
with a whole lot of people normally in
law school anyway so maybe it's best to
get law school out of the way
while everyone is cooped up and then you
know you can leave law school and
re-enter society like a normal human
being maybe that's not so bad
which supreme court justice flushed the
toilet on today's conference call
oh man this was a huge huge deal someone
actually flushed the toilet
uh while on an oral argument with the
supreme court now the supreme court
famously
doesn't allow video cameras inside of
the the courthouse itself so you get a
bunch of these like uh
oil and pen uh paintings of people while
they're presenting an oral argument
but now in the coronavirus times they
have had to adapt and they had to go
to uh a dial-in voice conference system
and of course one of the first
oral arguments that this was happening
someone wasn't on mute
and you could hear a toilet flushing in
the background and what the fcc has said
is that when
the subject matter of the call ranges to
the topic
then the call is transformed john
roberts must have been
apoplectic because he cares about uh how
the court is perceived
and if there's plumbing in the
background of an oral argument you can
just imagine how
furious he must have been not uh not
great for the
um the image of the supreme court
all right what law school looks like
from facebook user trust me i'm a lawyer
i mean this is this is actually what law
school looks like this is not
a joke so one of these books is a case
book
and then a couple of these books are
supplements i think there's another case
book and then
uh there are you know obviously tons and
tons of highlight
i would say that this actually
under-represents how much
highlighting and interliniation and
note-taking you actually take in little
plastic flags in the book law students
actually have to deal with this crap
alright how they welcome newly hired
associates to a law firm
some of you may die but it's a sacrifice
i'm willing to make
so here's the thing with big firms they
pay a huge amount of money
they expect for you to basically devote
your life
to the big firm when you are a young
associate and they will actually train
you how to be a lawyer
at the highest levels of jurisprudence i
actually think it's a reasonable
trade-off i was in the big firm world
for
10 years and i learned to practice at
the absolute highest levels of
federal court in high high-level state
court proceedings
for a long time i was completely devoted
to that big firm and i
actually wouldn't trade that forever you
know the phrase they don't pay me enough
for this crap
well big firms actually do pay you
enough for that crap whatever that crap
is
you kind of have to do it and it's a
reasonable tradeoff because law school
doesn't really
teach you how to be a lawyer you have to
learn that on the job not for everyone
uh it's hard to get into but the
trade-off is sometimes worth it
when you start working at your first job
after law school i don't know
about all right i think we had to
probably bleep that one out so as i was
just saying you graduate from law school
you don't know anything you don't know
about so true which is why it's often a
good idea to work for a big firm or
another experienced lawyer who knows
what they're doing
because when you graduate from law
school you don't know anything
all right in keeping with the practice
me coming up with multiple good points
after the hearing
oh with the drag on the cigarette it
happens every time
well most of the time because you're at
oral argument you're at a hearing
and in the spur of the moment the judge
has some crazy question you really
really try and shed this as hard as you
can you come up with
as many arguments as you can you talk
with your co-workers you talk with your
friends you try and come up with every
argument you possibly can but inevitably
there's gonna be something you didn't
think of and of course the second that
you leave the courthouse
you think of all of these great
arguments that you could have made
and you didn't
say lovey
all right i shall grant you three wishes
i wish for a world without lawyers
done you have no more wishes but you
said three sue me
uh i love variations of this joke uh
because everyone hates lawyers
until you need one and then then who are
you gonna call
hmm
[Music]
all right the judge threw out our case
don't worry i brought it back to him
illegal corgi legal corgis have become
a real thing uh i think it was partially
because of george conway
and his love of corgis and there are a
couple other legal commentators that
just have corgis and
love them so they've sort of been
appropriated as the
dog of the legal profession this is a
good boy he brought his case back
first we'll file a baseless voter fraud
claim then it will be 12b6 with
prejudice
then we'll get rule 11 sanctions then
we'll get rule 11 sanctions
so this pretty much sums up all of the
elections cases
in general a 12b6 is famously a motion
to dismiss in federal court it is
something that you file when the claims
themselves don't rise to the level of a
legal claim as a
matter of law and then when that is uh
filed then you can get rule 11 sanctions
against the counterparty
though actually oh i don't think this is
accurate because rule 11 sanctions
require you
to file a motion for rule of in
sanctions uh
then the other party gets a safe harbor
provision they can withdraw
their offending pleading i'd have to
check the case law on this but i'm not
sure if you get
the case dismissed on a 12b6 that you
can then go back
and get rule 11 sanctions because at
that point the case has already been
dismissed
and uh you weren't able to allow them
the safe harbor and the withdrawal
so you might have to file your rule 11
motion before you file your 12b6 i'll
have to think about that
perhaps not an accurate legal meme here
i don't know you know i would have
expected more legal accuracy from pixar
or dreamworks or
whichever this what is it minions
mastermind i i i can't remember
is my client guilty probably but
probably is not good enough
i've actually never heard it said that
way but this this is accurate so
if you are talking about guilt then you
are in
the criminal law world which means that
you're talking about the standard of
beyond a reasonable doubt
probably just means that you are 51
sure now probably can also encompass
more certainty than that
but probably in my mind brings up the
civil standard of preponderance of the
evidence which again is just
barely more than 50 more likely than not
so you've got the defense case and the
plaintiff's case
and whichever one is more likely that's
who you have to find for
civil cases don't have a beyond a
reasonable doubt standard i probably
would not argue this in a criminal
context but
it is true if you only probably think
that someone committed a criminal crime
then you can't find them guilty that's
not good enough
okay looks like we're back to law school
again first day of med school each of
you is brilliant and will change the
world here's a white coat go
and do well first day of law school
you're all dumb for doing this
the four of you who survive will work
for evil corporations here's a 100-page
reading assignment
it's due two hours from now yeah yeah
i'll have to talk to doc and mike about
this one
i don't know if they actually said
you're all brilliant and here's a white
lab coat on day one i kind of doubt that
i'll have to find out from him the law
school stuff is a little bit more
accurate
though while there are definitely
hundred page reading assignments they
aren't due two hours from now and
there's really
no assignment you don't really get
tested until the very end of the
semester which i think is actually worse
instead of having lots of little
assignments to do along the way
you're only tested by really one big
assignment at the end and sometimes
there might be a midterm in the middle
now more than four people are going to
survive and not all of them are going to
work for evil corporations but
definitely
yeah some of them some of them will
all right going with how i met your
mother ways in which you're wrong ways
in which i'm right
lawyered i loved marshall in uh how i
met your mother
there's one particular episode where
he's being wined and dined by a giant
law firm we've talked a lot about giant
law firms
today it's so funny because he's being
wine and dying not only with kobe steak
but also kobe lobster which is
lobster that's been fed nothing but kobe
steak you can really taste the beef in
that lobster
i think that is one of the funniest uh
and most accurate depictions of being
blind and dined by these
these you know huge law firms they are
going to work you to death but at least
you'll get a nice steak dinner out of it
made non-equity partner so i guess you
could say things are getting pretty
serious
oh this is a deep cut let me see if i
can explain this in the law firm world
you have partners the partners are the
bosses they tend to be the managers the
supervisors and there are two kinds of
partners there is an equity partner who
shares in the profits of a law firm
and then there's a non-equity partner
that is basically just a senior
associate that gets a nice title and
maybe some more
responsibility and on top of that they
probably have to pay into the
partnership
as well so it's kind of the worst of all
worlds you don't get
all that much more you don't share in a
profit sharing agreement with the firm
itself because you don't have any equity
so yeah things are are getting pretty
serious
because they're not jeez
oh my god i'm going to get so many phone
calls for my my friends who are
non-equity partners in law firms
yeah well sucks to be them
uh my face when someone argues when the
ruling is in their favor with the tucker
confused face
oh this is so great i have seen so many
lawyers
who just they can't help themselves they
really like to hear the sound of their
own voice
and so they're in a hearing they're
winning with the judge the judge is
going to rule in their favor
and they just keep talking pro tip if
the judge is going to rule in your favor
shut up and i have seen lawyers uh
snatch defeat from the jaws of victory
because they just want to keep
talking all right
speaking of mercurial judges when both
parties agree to a continuance but the
judge denies it
this happens so much too so again uh the
judge
through their proxy the court clerk can
set their own schedule and oftentimes
both parties will agree to a continuance
of a hearing or
trial or whatever but the parties don't
get to agree to these things they have
to get the judge to sign off on these
things
and the judge is going to judge
especially in federal court where the
judge
just doesn't care about anyone else uh
because they're the master of their own
universe
assault with a deadly weapon oh that's
cute i think everybody gets this one
no explanation needed
mps esquire says do you wear glasses in
a face pass due to covid19
if so you may be entitled to
condensation
so true so look look i'm gonna laugh at
dad jokes
i just am sorry
hey this magic 8-ball just keeps saying
it depends oh that's the special lawyer
edition
oh i mean you guys know this it always
depends the law is complicated
facts are complicated you're gonna ask
me a legal question and i'm gonna tell
you
it depends so ooh that's a great merch
idea would you guys buy that a special
legal eagle edition of a magic 8-ball
that just says it depends on
on every role
[Music]
all right and the next meme is i wanted
to be a lawyer but i didn't have the
stomach for it
it's a shark look you got to be a shark
sometimes when especially when you're in
litigation not so much if you're a
transactional lawyer but
even if you are a transactional lawyer
sometimes you have to have those kind of
killer instincts to get the business
deals done but the litigators certainly
need to have shark-like instincts or
even more than shark-like instincts
because
the sharks sometimes don't have the
stomachs for it but of course seeing the
shark makes me really want to go to the
beach because the weather is getting so
much nicer
but of course my allergies are getting
terrible
you know what allergies be damned i am
going to the beach the weather is too
nice and of course to do that i have to
change out of my custom indochino suit
and wear something more casual and for
that i turn
to mac weldon if i'm not in court or on
a zoom call with a judge uh i'm often
wearing mac weldon or i'm at home
wearing pajamas but mac walden is my
choice for wearing stuff outside of the
house which i haven't done and
seemingly forever because they focus on
smart design and premium fabrics mac
walden is probably best well known for
their insanely comfortable boxer briefs
including their brand new stealth boxer
brief which is
great for working out or just hanging
out i wish i could show you one but
oh wait a minute these things are so
comfortable i forgot i was actually
wearing them i wish you could feel how
comfortable this is it's it's
insanely comfortable and if you're
watching this channel you're probably
an adult and you probably deserve to
have nice boxer briefs and i can tell
you it makes a world of difference
i also love their incredibly comfortable
polos like these and their radius pants
which are halfway between slacks and
joggers so i don't have to choose
between wearing something
incredibly comfortable like sweatpants
and looking presentable like an actual
human being when i
decide to actually leave the house and
speaking of which i don't even have to
leave the house to order macweldon i
just order multiple sizes have them
shipped to my home
and just return the ones that don't fit
right and keep the ones that fit
perfectly
so if you would like to try macweldon
you can get 20 off your first order just
go to macweldon.com
legal eagle or use the promo code
legaleagle at checkout or of course
you can click on the link below in the
description which really helps out this
channel
and of course mack weldon's loyalty
program will get you 20 off plus free
shipping and access to new products
before everybody else it's automatic
when you sign up and order at
macweldon.com
legaleagle so as we all re-enter society
you owe it to yourself to get some
insanely comfortable great-looking
clothes from mac weldon and of course
if you want to try their famous boxer
briefs and you decide for any reason
that you're not satisfied
you can just keep them and still get a
refund because nobody wants to return
used underwear so again just click on
the link and go to macweldon.com
legal eagle or use the promo code
legaleagle for 20 off your first order
and
clicking on those links really helps out
this channel and it'll help you
look fly so do you have some legal memes
or some legal jokes that i should
respond to please let me know in the
comments below and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other real lawyer reactions
and of course my
famous legal meme reviews so click on
this playlist or i'll see you
in court